Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
L’essence même de la photographie
est de regarder vers l’extérieur.
Je pense à ces photographes de l’époque
qui s’effaçaient
derrière leurs tissus noirs
pour des raisons techniques.
Mais symboliquement,
ils disparaissaient
aussi derrière ce drap.
Aujourd’hui, lorsque je vois
des gens faire des selfies,
c'est tout le contraire.
On fait partie de la photo,
on se met dans le cadre.
On n’est plus dans une démarche d’un
regard vers l’autre mais plutôt vers soi.
Comme si le monde n’a de sens
que si je suis moi-même dedans.
Lorsque j’étais enfant,
je rêvais d’être comédienne.
J'ai longtemps cherché à répondre
au regard de l'autre sur moi.
Je cherchais une reconnaissance
à travers mon image
en pensant devenir comédienne,
donc au-devant de la scène.
En fait, je faisais fausse route.
Je pense que vous serez
un peu d’accord avec moi.
Ce regard de l’autre
me mettait dans une gêne.
Je ne trouvais pas ma place.
À l’école, un professeur avait
même dit à mes parents
que je n’arriverais à rien dans ma vie.
C’est vrai que j’étais rêveuse,
un peu atypique,
je ne rentrais pas dans le moule.
Je ne vous cacherai pas que ce professeur,
je le croiserais volontiers aujourd’hui,
parce que j’aurais pas mal
de choses à lui dire.
Mais par chance,
je suis née avec un troisième œil.
J’ai mis du temps à m’en rendre compte
tellement j’étais habitée
par toutes sortes de doutes.
Mais lorsque je l’ai compris,
il était évident
que j’allais devenir photographe.
Nous, photographes, ceux du troisième œil,
nous voyons le monde différemment.
Je pense que nous voyons
le monde avec un autre regard
et on voit des choses
que d’autres ne voient pas.
Une courbe, un instant, une mimique.
Et j’allais enfin faire quelque chose
de cette hypersensibilité
débordante à travers mes images.
Cette prise de conscience
de regarder vers l’extérieur,
de m’oublier et de me construire
à travers mon regard sur le monde
et non plus l’inverse,
m’a permis enfin de trouver ma place
en me positionnant derrière
et non pas devant la caméra.
Pour moi, ce troisième œil est
un fixateur de l’émotion humaine.
Vous savez quoi ?
Ça m’allait parfaitement bien.
Alors, je me suis dirigée vers
la photographie documentaire
et tout particulièrement sur
la place de la femme dans le monde.
Il y a un peu plus de dix ans,
j’ai entamé un travail sur le long terme
dans dix communautés
aux quatre coins du monde
où la femme a une place centrale.
A l’époque, je ne savais pas encore
qu’en fait c’était l’histoire de ma vie
et que tout mon parcours m’a amenée
à choisir cette thématique.
C’était au Yémen,
où pour la première fois,
j’ai ressenti ce bonheur simple
d’être à l’autre bout du monde
sur le terrain où tout était à découvrir.
C'était comme une révélation,
un électrochoc.
Et depuis, à chaque reportage,
j’ai l’impression de renaître.
J’admirais aussi toutes ces femmes
aventurières d’un autre temps,
qui ont eu le courage de vivre des vies
qui ne leur étaient pas destinées.
Des femmes comme Isabelle Eberhardt
qui, au XIXᵉ siècle,
est partie seule en Algérie,
dans le désert, déguisée en homme
ou l’artiste Frida Kahlo
pour son engagement
à contre-courant de son époque
et son inspiration auprès
des femmes de Juchitán
que j’ai moi-même eu la chance
et l’honneur de photographier.
Ici à Juchitán, au Mexique,
chez les Zapotèques,
ce sont les hommes qui sont
en charge de la matière brute -
l’agriculture et la pêche -
et ce sont les femmes qui
fructifient cette matière brute
en la commercialisant
sur le marché qui est 100% féminin.
C’est aussi la femme
qui gère la bourse familiale
et la naissance d’une fille
est vivement célébrée,
étant donné que c’est elle
qui héritera des biens.
J’ai voulu raconter des récits de femme,
de leurs différents statuts dans le monde.
Tout a commencé avec
le mot « matriarcat »,
ce mot qui d’ailleurs n’est pas retenu
par la plupart des anthropologues.
La majorité des gens
pensent que le matriarcat
est un système dans
lequel la femme domine.
Ce qui voudrait dire qu’elle a
le pouvoir absolu au sens pyramidal,
comme c’est le cas
dans les sociétés patriarcales.
Or, ce n’est pas le cas,
elles ne dominent pas les hommes
elles sont leurs égales.
Il est donc plus juste de parler
de société matrilinéaire,
un système de filiation par la mère,
et de matrilocale lorsque l’homme
est une sorte d’invité chez la femme.
Dans ce travail, je propose
de partager avec vous
une autre façon de voir
les rapports entre humains.
Maintenant, nous passons à la Chine.
En Chine, c’est une société
typiquement matrilinéaire.
Nous sommes dans le Yunnan,
chez les Moso, qui sont environ 40 000.
J’ai pris cette photo de cette « dabu »
qui est donc la cheffe de clan.
C’est elle qui transmet le nom,
qui transmet les biens,
la maison, les terres,
qui gère les ressources financières,
qui prend les décisions importantes.
Il va de soi que son rôle
est très important.
Je me promenais par là
et lorsque je l’ai croisée,
j’ai engagé une conversation avec elle.
À un moment donné, je lui ai demandé
si elle aurait voulu avoir un mari.
Elle m’a regardée un peu surprise
et elle a éclaté de rire et elle m’a
renvoyé la question en me disant :
« Mais pour quoi faire ? »
Effectivement, dans cette communauté,
le contrat de mariage n’existe pas.
Ils pratiquent ce qu’ils appellent
la visite du mariage.
Sur cette photo, on voit
au premier plan un homme,
c’est « azous », c’est l’amant,
Lui fait une sorte de va-et-vient entre
la maison de sa mère ou de sa sœur
et de sa bien-aimée où il n’est
jamais véritablement chez lui.
Dans la langue moso,
le mot « père » n’existe pas,
étant donné que lorsqu’un
enfant vient au monde,
l’oncle maternel sera
le tuteur de l’enfant
mais le père biologique ne le sera pas.
Je vous présente le pays musulman
le plus important au monde,
le plus grand au monde,
mais aussi la communauté matrilinéaire
la plus grande au monde.
Nous sommes sur l’île
de Sumatra, en Indonésie,
et ils sont tout de même six millions
chez les Minangkabau.
Ce qui est étonnant dans cette communauté,
c’est que dans l’Islam,
la fille hérite d’un tiers.
Or, chez les Minangkabau,
c’est la fille qui hérite des biens.
Et lorsqu’un couple se marie,
contrairement aux Moso en Chine
où ils ne se marient pas,
le mari doit quitter son clan familial
et s’installer dans
le clan familial de sa femme,
ce qui en fait une communauté matrilocale.
Là, nous sommes en Afrique.
Contrairement aux communautés
dont je viens de vous parler,
les Moso, les Minangkabau
et les Zapotèques,
les Samburu et Turkana
qui sont au nord du Kenya,
c’est un tout autre exemple.
C’est beaucoup plus récent
car les autres communautés
ont plus de 2000 ans.
C’est vraiment un phénomène qui
a à peine une vingtaine d’années
et c’est aussi très différent
comme exemple.
Ce regroupement de femmes est
plus un mouvement de résistance.
Ces femmes ont inventé
des traditions sans hommes.
Non parce qu’elles sont contre les hommes.
C’est juste qu’elles ont toutes vécu
des histoires violentes avec les hommes.
Elles ont donc fondé ce village
par besoin de retrouver leur dignité.
J’ai un véritable coup de cœur pour
ces femmes, pour cette communauté.
D’abord, j’étais en admiration
de leur courage,
car elles vivent quand même
dans un monde très hostile.
Et j’ai décidé de créer une petite
association pour venir à leur aide.
Modeste à mon niveau,
on a ouvert une petite école
et j’estime que dans notre métier,
il est important -
Souvent, c’est malheureusement impossible
mais quand on peut, on essaye d’aider
parce qu’on vient, on débarque,
on dérange un petit peu
et surtout on est confronté à des gens
qui vivent dans des conditions difficiles.
Si on peut, on essaie de ramener
quelque chose, de donner un retour.
Toujours en Afrique, de l’autre côté,
du côté ouest, en Guinée-Bissau,
chez les Bijagos, sur l’île de Canhabaque.
Là, ce sont les femmes
qui règnent sur le monde spirituel
en accueillant l’esprit des hommes morts.
A ce propos, certaines photos
m'ont été interdites.
Les esprits, m’a-t-on dit,
m’ont accueillie moi, m’ont acceptée.
Ce qui était un honneur pour moi.
Mais mon appareil photo
n’était pas le bienvenu.
Je ne vous cache pas
que voir toutes ces photos défiler,
qui ne verraient jamais le jour
a été une réelle frustration.
Mais ça fait partie de la règle du jeu.
Il faut accepter les coutumes locales
et faire avec.
Beaucoup plus au nord,
nous sommes chez le peuple touareg,
ce peuple noble qui est réparti
sur cinq pays d’Afrique.
Nous sommes dans le Sahara algérien.
Là encore, c’est la femme qui transmet
la culture à travers les chants,
les danses, la langue,
les contes et légendes.
Et lorsqu’un couple s’unit,
c’est encore la femme
qui hérite des biens.
Là, en occurrence, le bétail,
la tente lorsqu’ils sont nomades,
ce qui est de plus en plus rare
car ils sont de plus en plus sédentarisés.
L’accès aux femmes a été un peu
difficile dans cette communauté.
On me mettait toujours avec les hommes,
ce qui était compliqué puisque
je faisais un travail sur les femmes.
Même si les hommes font bien sûr
partie de toutes ces communautés,
l’accent était quand même sur les femmes.
Finalement, une jeune Touareg
a dû avoir un peu pitié de moi
et m’a prise sous son aile,
m’a introduite dans le cercle des femmes
où j’ai enfin pu tisser des liens,
être à leur rencontre
et faire mon travail.
Je pense que c’est
mon appareil photo qui a agressé -
Les anciennes se sentaient
agressées par mon appareil photo.
Dans le reportage,
les gens pensent souvent
qu’il suffit d’être
à l’autre bout du monde,
dans un décor idyllique,
exotique, et de faire clic.
Mais c’est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça.
Il y a tout un processus par lequel
on doit passer d’acceptation
et en très peu de temps.
Parce qu’en fait, on débarque,
on bouscule des choses,
on rentre dans l’intimité
de la vie des gens.
Donc, ce n’est pas évident
qu’ils vous acceptent tout de suite.
Il y a tout ce travail qui est
quand même très important
où il faut un petit peu charmer les gens
et faire tout un travail
psychologique presque.
Pour qu’après, ils vous acceptent
finalement dans leur cercle.
Là, on change de continent,
on va aux États-Unis,
dans l’une des plus grandes réserves
amérindiennes, la Nation navajo.
J’ai choisi de partager
cette photo avec vous
parce que je trouve, pour moi en tout cas,
que ces trois femmes incarnent
la force de toutes ces femmes
que j’ai rencontrées à travers
toutes ces communautés.
Et elle fait aussi partie
des photos emblématiques
de tout ce travail.
Toujours chez les Navajo.
Une fois par an est célébré
le concours de Miss Navajo.
Contrairement à nos Miss qui défilent
tout de même en maillot de bain
et qui sont jugées essentiellement
pour leurs atouts physiques,
là, c’est une tout autre histoire.
Ces femmes doivent connaître
la culture Navajo sur le bout des doigts,
la langue, leur histoire,
la spiritualité, les danses, les chants.
Et elles doivent abattre un mouton,
au grand dam de mon fils
qui adore les moutons.
Elles doivent le faire
dans l’art de leur culture,
après l’avoir caressé et béni.
La gagnante deviendra ambassadrice
de la nation Navajo
et devra promouvoir
sa culture à travers le pays.
Beaucoup moins exotique,
et géographiquement plus proche de nous,
ce sont les femmes de Ouessant en Bretagne
et celles de Kihnu en Estonie.
Deux îles qui sont
à 3 000 kilomètres l’une de l’autre,
mais qui partagent
pratiquement la même histoire.
Les hommes partaient longtemps,
des mois et des mois,
dans la marine marchande,
les femmes restaient seules
et devaient donc tout gérer.
Elles sont devenues
les gardiennes de l’île.
J’ai eu la chance de rencontrer
ces gardiennes de l’île,
celles qui ont encore connu cette époque.
Aujourd'hui, elles sont toutes âgées
et certaines plus de ce monde.
Dans les nouvelles générations,
il n’y a plus de gardienne de l’île,
mais leur image et leur symbole
inspirent toujours le respect.
Je tiens vraiment à remercier
toutes ces personnes qui m’ont accueillie,
qui m’ont ouvert leurs portes
dans leur univers hors du commun,
qui m’ont laissé rentrer
dans leur intimité
et dans leur autre façon de faire.
Certaines de ces communautés
disparaissent, d’autres perdurent,
et de nouvelles se créent.
Mais ce qui est incroyable,
c’est cet équilibre qui intègre les hommes
sans jamais les dominer.
Ce travail m’a apporté
confiance et espoir en moi,
mais aussi à un autre avenir,
peut-être plus égalitaire.
Certaines librairies ont placé mon livre
sur ce travail « Les Matriarches »
dans le rayon Ethnologie.
Pas si mal que ça pour celle qui,
d’après le professeur,
n’arriverait à rien dans sa vie.
Moi, ça me fait sourire.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)